[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone thank you for coming
um i'll remind the people who are not in
the room with us that you can uh send us
questions on chat at any point and we'll
take a look at those once we get open to
get to open discussion
um our guest today is martha minnow who
has taught at harvard law school and
where she's also served as dean since
1981 in addition to saving the news uh
the subtitle which is why the
constitution calls for government action
to preserve freedom of freedom of speech
which is the book we're talking about
today
um she's the author of when when should
law forgive from 2019
in brown's wake
legacies of america's constitutional
landmark from 2010 among many other
books and articles she's an expert in
human rights and advocacy for members of
racial and religious minorities and for
women
children and persons with disabilities
she also writes and teaches about
digital communications democracy
privatization military justice and
ethnic and religious conflict
i am heather hendershot director of a
graduate studies and comparative media
studies and um i work on
political media right-wing media news
media and i've got a book coming out
this late this fall called um
when the news broke chicago 1968 and the
polarizing uh polarization of america
and my last book was on william f
buckley's firing line and the one before
that was on cold war right wing
broadcasting so those are the books that
i've done that are sort of most relevant
i think to our discussion today um what
we're gonna do is take about 45 minutes
or so it's flexible um for for martha
and i to go back and forth and and talk
about her book and i expect she'll do
most of the talking because she knows
more about her book than i do but um i
read it with great interest and made up
tons of i'm surrounded by pages with
notes on them around me here so i i did
bring in a few ideas
um and then we'll open up for general
discussion and and q a with the idea of
ending somewhere between 6 15 and 6 30.
um
so uh
this uh book saving the news
is
it's a
a tight 150 pages but i feel like i've
read a thousand page book because
there's so much material in it it's so
action-packed and uh uh and packed with
detail and um i encourage you all to
procure it and to read it um but i'll
just give you the spoiler but there's
there's four chapters and then there's a
coda at the end that is almost like an
op-ed to just like condense everything
from the book into it so it's a great
way to
um get the
really key ideas of the book before you
dive in
um
and the the structure is great you've
got two chapters sort of setting up the
problem and two chapters setting up the
solution and the viability of various
solutions
um
and the the problem
is uh
is is laid out as the you know the
crisis in news right now
um on on various fronts on technological
fronts uh you know the the crisis of the
way that algorithms work the crisis of
the creation of echo chambers
um
and
in particular in the beginning of the
book
uh martha talks about the
decline of
print journalism and uh
local newspapers in particular and she
emphasizes the firing of staff layoffs
reduction you know uh
and and how this is a sort of a threat
to
uh democracy or rather
you know how important
the the existence of journalism is to
democracy in the us in fact she ends the
book dramatically by saying you know
constitution calls out you know one
business the news business explicitly um
because we need news to have a thriving
democracy um
and then in the second half of the book
she asked him does the first amendment
forbid permit or require government
support of news industries how could we
find ways to support news industries
within the parameters of the first
amendment which we absolutely can she
argues
um and what you know what kind of
reforms could we make so i wonder if we
don't have to be too rigid but we could
sort of uh start by taking the book in
order and look at that first half about
how she lays out the problems
uh that that we're facing in the the
crisis if you will and um i'm going to
read just one i'm i post this i'm gonna
post it personally i've got a thousand
post-its here and they're all like read
this aloud read that aloud um and it's
really too much but i i did mark one
passage from uh early on from pitch 34
that um i thought was particularly
interesting that i'm going to read to
you uh just to kick it off a little bit
i'll give you a sense of the prose style
um she writes the government was once
assumed to be the main threat to the
quote marketplace of ideas through
punishments or bans on publication but
now the greater danger comes through
overwhelming individuals with messages
that swamp meaningful communication
although
quote more is better once seemed a
sensible approach to freedom of speech
the more provided by digital resources
may destroy professional journalism
undermine public confidence and
information and negatively affect the
provision and absorption of information
needed for self-government the current
situation differs from prior disruptions
because now the very viability of new
enterprises of getting local regional
national and international news to
people is under siege
and
you know the there's a sense in which
and we can talk more about the scarcity
rationale for previous regulation as we
we move forward but you know the
rationale for fcc and other kinds of
government censors or not censorship but
regulation used to be uh the notion of
scarcity that we have a broadcast
spectrum that is scarce and has to be
allocated and it's a scarce resource
that is owned by the public and you
might say that excess is the new
scarcity in a sense
now there is too much
uh out there and that this is uh you
know the flip side but also a rationale
for certain kinds of regulation or
action to be taken
um
so having said that i wonder martha if
you could unpack for us a bit
the parameters of the the the crisis
that you delineate in the book the
problems that you see
thanks so much and thanks for the
introduction and for the background i'm
a huge mary tyler moore fan
um
so what what i
can say is that there really is a
confluence of multiple events that have
uh joined together to create a world in
which we have simultaneously
decline shrinkage of the numbers of
people who actually make a living
as journalists pursuing some kind of
fact-based
accounts of what's going on or even
accountability investigative journalism
uh dramatic
decline particularly in the local news
over the last 20 to 30 years
you know something like
half to two-thirds of the numbers of
people who made a living as journalists
now no longer do
that's one problem another problem is
the flooding particularly in digital
context but not only also in cable and
broadcast
of information into people's worlds
but it may not just be information it's
communications and many of them actually
not reliable
many of them
either
the product of people deliberately
trying to mislead or the product of bots
the bottom of of foreign governments uh
people who are making money simply by
creating click bait
uh so that's the second problem that's
creating this doubt about the
reliability of any information uh
the
the rand corporation calls it truth
decay
and
suspicion about any source
um and then there's a third problem
which is the decline of any kind of
trust in any institution in this country
and in particular the fragility of
democracies in this country but also in
other countries around the world and
it's the confluence of those three that
really led me to write this book
the
causes
of the decline that first
crisis are multiple
um
one is the introduction of the internet
every new technology has jeopardized the
press which as heather said is the only
private industry that's mentioned in the
united states constitution and not only
mentioned but given its own distinct
constitutional protections
so when we move from printing presses
to radio people worried this will be the
end but it certainly was not same with
television but it certainly was not each
time there was a successive creation we
can include telegraph
as well
of a new media it actually
opened up more information and more more
desire more demand for information
sometimes uh shifting
where people get their breaking
information from where they get their
more detailed background information
but the internet is a little different
the good news is everyone knows is it
lowers the barriers to entry uh the
costs are low um just you know turn over
your data that's about it um but the
the
difficulty is the very strength is also
the weakness the elimination of an
intermediary or a clear intermediary who
is judging whether or not what's being
amplified is worth being amplified means
that now there can be crazy stuff that's
amplified all the time uh and so that's
that's a big problem but there's a
financial dimension to it as well
so the
migration of advertising
from conventional media to the internet
uh about 75 percent of advertising is
now that used to be
for television or print media is now on
the internet and it's escalating even
beyond that and we all know why it's
because there can be the targeted ads
uh there can be the sculpting of the
message
for subgroups some people call it
digital gerrymandering
um and it's even cheaper and that has
really kicked out from under
conventional media
one of the pillars of its financial
model
another pillar of its financial model
also decimated by the internet is the
subscription
so subscriptions why subscribe when you
can see someone tweet the headline why
subscribe when you can see someone cut
and paste
uh the results of three months of
investigative journalism without
charging at all
um and you know the conventional media
made a mistake initially thinking well
we'll just give our stuff away for free
uh and without building a paywall you
know only the wall street job journal
figured out you start with a paywall um
but uh
retroactive clawbacks trying to get some
kind of payment for copyrighted material
has just totally failed
so
that's the second pillar of the
traditional finance model uh for media
so if you don't have subscriptions and
you don't have ads what do you have
um
and and yet and here's just one more
piece
most of the print
local news uh is still making money it's
not making the kind of money
that lots of investors want it's not
double digits but it makes money and
that has made it an attractive target
for venture capitalists uh in private
equity which buy up
local papers and chains and papers and
even radio stations and even television
stations and then proceed to strip mine
them for their assets and that has
accelerated the firing and the
elimination of actual staff so you have
newspapers that are ghost papers that
have no staff
and they circulate you know
features that are written
that are very adenine and don't actually
pertain to anything about a unique
community
and no surprise subscriptions diminish
and ads diminish so it's a very vicious
cycle so all that adds up to there's a
financial crisis
um for the news industry specifically
but for traditional media generally
um
you talked about um
late in the book uh unbundling and the
kind of uh you know once uh
craigslist appeared and people could get
their classifieds online then they
didn't need to pay for classifieds in
newspapers but i think another key issue
there was that once entertainment
content
whether
uh farts
cookies sports become separate out from
hard news um i think that the picture
there is that those features and here
i'm thinking like in particular matthew
pressman's book on matthew pressman's
book on press right on the the rise of
lifestyle features sure way to make a
ton of money and also to support the
hard news and once those things become
extrapolated out and you can get say all
your cooking articles without
subsidizing the news reporting why
subsidize the news reporting right
so
um i thought that was just another
important angle on this i don't want to
jump too far ahead to solutions because
that's that's later in the book later
but that's a great point and the cross
subsidy of the
of the traditional media um
just as you're describing actually also
carried with it another consequence that
we're losing which is serendipity
bumping into something that wasn't
already something you signed up for or
that it was targeted based on everything
you've seen before
um and that really contributes to
polarization that people are seeing
entirely different uh materials uh and
they're not living in the same universe
[Music]
i wonder if you could talk also about
some of the sort of really helpful
history lessons that you give in the
book to help us understand
that
the
the government subsidizing of the press
and of of public utilities and
infrastructure in the u.s is really
relevant to thinking about the president
because i don't think most people who
think about the crisis in news today are
like what happened with canals railroads
uh
you know um or even like what was
arpanet you know so i wonder if you
could fill us in on that history and why
that's relevant not just something that
history nerds need to know but like
relevant to thinking about the present
oh thanks so much
you know the first amendment is is
written as if the government just is
hands off
uh that no state shall make a law
restricting the freedom of expression or
the freedom of the press
but the history i actually looked for
somebody to tell me the history and i
couldn't find it so i had to write it
and i found you know a lot of fantastic
studies about
sub elements but i tried to put it
together and it is a fascinating story
about three ways in which government has
underwritten subsidized or structured
communications technologies in the
united states from the founding on the
first is uh actual money subsidies
from the post office on the post office
is right there in the constitution
congress can create a post office and
from the very beginning of the post
office
it provided subsidies to
newspapers it created a cheaper rate for
their distribution and actually made
free the distribution of one newspaper
to another newspaper and that kind of
subsidy has continued on into the
present
uh other areas where direct subsidies
exist we are all familiar with public
broadcasting that's a subsidy um but
there there are others as well so take
for example development of telegraph you
know the united states government the
navy was the first purchaser of
telegraph
machines
um and then there are somewhat more
subtle forms of government support for
example
the
way in which the government actually
took land
government has the power to take private
land if it gives compensation it took
land to make it available to telegraph
providers to the same way it did for
railroads
and of course it took the
licensing power this is the second way
in which the government has structured
the media the licensing power you refer
to dealing with the scarcity of signals
for radio and then television but also
even for cable
and with a kind of regulatory oversight
restricting the numbers of people so
that there won't be too much uh
interference but also then layering on
some public service obligations so
that's the second way the government's
structuring markets
regulating than the duties attached to
the markets
and the third way
is a little more complicated which is
the bundle of rules from antitrust
to public utility to
other areas where the law actually does
a combination of subsidy structuring
markets creating liabilities creating
immunities and just as an example
um
section 230 of the communications
decency act is in essence a subsidy to
the
internet platforms but not to
conventional media because the internet
platforms are literally immunized from
legal rules that apply
to everybody else rules against
defamation rules against uh any other
kind of consumer protection violation um
and that makes it cheaper for the
internet companies to operate
other examples as you note you know the
government very much this is states and
federal government invested in the
creation of
an infrastructure during the 19th
century and the 20th century some of
that was communications infrastructure
the internet itself is a perfect example
the department of defense paid for the
research and the building of arpanet
which then became the internet the
national science foundation gave a grant
that led to the very first algorithms of
google and we can go on and on and on so
the government actually structuring the
possibilities investing in the
development of new technologies
regulating the market structure deciding
when to enforce antitrust law and when
not to
has all
meant that the government's fingerprints
are entirely all over the current
situation
um
i agree with a lot of what you're saying
i want to
push back or complicate one thing and
ask you to expand on another thing um
the first is that i think throughout the
book when you talk about past regulation
that has worked really well in certain
ways
you tend to paint that regulation in a
in a very positive or benign light and i
think some people
would push back against that i think
like when i'm reading your work i'm
thinking about like robert mcchesney
writing about the amateur radio movement
and how government regulations
ultimately
like help corporations and
help americans get access to media and
so on but they help corporations by
shutting out amateurs but also help
corporations by not letting the navy
have a monopoly say on on on radio um
and uh
uh
you know that that
or or even the going back further to
thinking about like the railroads like
taking land is not a benign thing who
had that land whose land right whose
land exactly exactly so i wonder if you
could um unpack that a little bit for us
and the the second part is um i'd like
to take some more time to talk about
section 230 but i think before i ask you
that i want to want you to respond the
first part and then we can switch a
little bit to talk about section 230.
you know i think a very fair criticism
of my work is that there's a tendency to
glorify parts of the past which had
their own major problems
even in its heyday when
mainstream media was
financially doing very well and
was distributed widely
there were real difficulties for the
black press
there were exclusions uh for women as
journalists really until what became
known as
uh the yellow journalism that's when
women really broke in and started to do
features and what's called yellow
journalism i think has to be recast it's
often women going incognito and exposing
uh locked uh insane asylums and back
door uh backdoor uh abortions but in any
case women had been largely excluded
from the media um and yes uh the the big
companies have always
tried to exclude anyone entering whether
it was conventional
um
the the newspaper owners that would buy
up competitors or uh the
the people who created networks in
broadcast and really shut down some
alternatives so all of that's true
there are choices being made there are
choices being made though i just want to
underscore not just in these very
obvious areas where government is
overtly acting their choices being made
when government is supposedly not acting
because when government's not acting
there are also rules that apply and so
all of this is to public policy this is
all choices what do we want and who's
accountable um to this day we have large
internet platforms that in some ways are
begging for regulation in part because
they're subject to competing rules from
different states and even different
countries but in part because the big
platforms would benefit um because they
could shut out competitors they have the
market capitalization that would allow
them to comply
um so those are always problems um but
having given uh that acknowledgement i
just want to say it's not like there's
an alternative without choices there
will be choices there's no such thing as
natural markets uh the property rights
underlying the markets are themselves
structured by law and by government
so in that sense it's what choices and
whose choices
right the hands may be invisible but the
hands are there right doing things
making choices um i was thinking about
frank stanton's line i think it was
frank stein of cbs who at one point said
um you know the licenses from the
government are like a license to print
money and the and the news divisions
justify it
and i thought that was it was a rare
moment because usually they just talked
about how great their news divisions
were but he was pointing to the fact
that
that we do public service through the
news
and that helps completely right
uh the beverly hillbillies and whatever
we want to put out to to sell ads and
and to make money um and that you know
that was like a cynical take on it at
the same time that there are sort of
some good reasons to romanticize that
era in news um i think you know for sure
and then just add another layer to it
there's this sense that in the past the
news divisions
um
were
so benevolent in serving their public
service doing public service performing
public service and so on and they were
kind of a lost leader for television
when in fact they made quite a bit of
money right like huntley brinkley took
in huge amounts of money um and
what you know i can't i don't remember
the exact numbers but you know they're
running five days a week and selling
tremendous amounts of ads and uh you
know
in the short term bringing in more money
than something like gun smoke which was
a blockbuster hit in the long term
they're not because they're not
syndicated and that's you know the
money's education but just to kind of um
like we long for that era but we also
need to complicate that era i guess it's
one well totally right and and let's
just recall it it was an era of two and
a half networks yeah abc only went to
half the country
so there was a kind of you know
oligopoly of just a few providers
um and the model of uh national networks
that then created content that most of
the locals carried um was was uh a way
to make money for sure
um but even then the local channels um
could for a brief period make money in
the news but mostly you're right it was
cross subsidy by entertainment and then
we have a wonderful movie broadcast news
to tell us about the conflicts about
what can news itself be entertaining and
all of those pressures about how do you
make news of interest to people and if
it bleeds it leads uh etc etc but you
know during very key periods in american
history the very fact that there was
such a shortage such a limited uh
availability of um of shared news meant
that we had shared experiences so if
there was a national crisis there was an
assassination of a president
everybody could tune in and watch the
same uh funeral
uh if there were other events everyone
could tune in and get the same account
that we do not have
we you you compare let's forget the
internet compare fox news and msnbc the
overlap in the topics not just the point
of view the topics
is a minority of what they cover
yeah and i would also add that in that
network era of news um i mean already by
the 60s people are getting more news
from tv than from newspapers right you
see a decline um
but i mean walter cronkite himself of
cbs news said that the news is a
headline service in a way that once
someone wants uh
in the newsroom to sort of poke at him
put up the front page of the new york
times and underline the parts that he
could have read aloud on the news and it
was like uh you know half the front page
of the new york times and the point
being that like there was 500 more pages
that you know didn't get covered um
and you know actually his his his uh
sign-off he was never really happy with
was you know and that's the way it is
but he used to in the early days he
signed off by with something like um
and to learn more read your local
newspaper because the assumption was i'm
just giving you like some leads for what
is interesting today and now you should
go learn more from
and interesting that's kind of coming
back with podcasts so that people can
actually dive deeper behind the
headlines uh and those uh outlets that
are succeeding are finding that the
viewership on podcast is going way up
the only problem is no one's figured out
how to make any money on a podcast
um
let's uh i i i previewed that i wanted
to talk about the section 230 of the of
the communications decency act and
i wonder if you could unpack that for us
a little bit and and and your book
is um
uh it it's very concerned you expressed
a lot of concern about this protection
from liability that section 230 allows
um and then you know on the
flip side there are
various kinds of
political positions from which people
speak who would like to eliminate 230
and some of it as you point out in the
book like at one point trump was saying
we gotta get rid of this yet and it
showed a complete misunderstanding of
what it actually meant which is no
surprise at all right he didn't really
get it um but then you have
i mean
well you just have competing voices who
would like to eliminate i'd like you to
talk about that a little bit and
and also concerns about what it would
mean to get rid of it for example in
terms of citizen journalism in terms of
i mean what if
uh if you if uh you eliminate section
230
and then platforms decide well we're not
going to show videos of any kind of uh
police officers because we may get uh in
legal trouble for that we're liable and
therefore if someone has footage of
police brutality priest violence we we
will choose not to show it because it's
it's the safer choice and i think that
um
i've seen a number of op-eds saying you
know the the uh awareness about george
floyd's murder for example sprang from
people being able to post this this
horrific video as evidence that this
thing happened and that if if platforms
were liable that video never would have
been allowed and that may or may not be
an overstatement but i'd like to hear
your take on
on that angle
so thanks uh when the communications
decency was act enacted which is where
section 230 uh was created
the internet was a fledgling entity it
was barely in existence
and the
concern that the legislators had was how
to shield this vulnerable new technology
from the competition from the behemoth
large broadcasters and others
and so
this immunity was invented as a way to
create a
space where there wouldn't be the kinds
of liabilities if you will that attach
to mature actors adult organizations in
the world that are responsible for their
actions
newspapers haven't shut down in the face
of defamation actions
uh and so the idea that now
the
largest
uh companies in the world the most
profitable companies in the world the
very large internet platforms would be
jeopardized by facing the same
liabilities that now their puny rivals
face is kind of laughable um and yet of
course it's you know very convenient for
the internet companies to claim that uh
they still need this protection
but let's be clear i'm not necessarily
arguing for eliminating it i'm arguing
for
modifying it perhaps by using it as a
way if it's so attractive to the large
companies to make it conditioned on some
public duties
you can still have your immunity if you
have some public service obligations
that you also have to fulfill
but now i have to do a little
constitutional law 101.
a lot of the people who have argued
from the trump perspective to eliminate
section 230 are confused about the first
amendment
and say that when there's a deep
platforming of someone say
donald trump that that's a violation of
the first amendment
constitutional law 101
private actors do not violate the first
amendment the first amendment restricts
the action of government no state shall
make the law
and therefore there is no first
amendment issue
if there is moderation if there is a
decision about who can uh amplify their
voice and who can't
uh
con law 102
uh the right to speak is not the right
to be amplified there is no right to
have your voice go for free to everyone
in the world
um and khan law 103
uh is that in fact the
internet uh
platforms just like the newspapers just
like the media networks they have first
amendment rights
their first amendment rights include
editing
that include the choices about what to
show what to amplify when and where
those are protected by the constitution
so the debate about section 230 has been
distorted by people who don't know
constitutional law um there are
last count something like two dozen
bills that have been introduced into
congress to alter modify or eliminate
section 230 but we could put aside about
half of them for this mistaken view
moreover
they
they themselves would violate the
constitution because they then are
government action government action
calling for
there should only be uh material that
shows the following or there should be
no material that shows the following
that violates the first amendment so
what's left are a variety of actions uh
proposals some of which are the kind
that i'm in favor of that would put some
uh quid pro quo you want this immunity
then in exchange there's some duties
that attach like responsible moderation
or like opening up the layer of uh
internet platforms that does moderation
to competition
or making transparent the criteria by
which moderation uh is performed none of
which are currently required
so if you think about
basic consumer protection law which is
also
not applicable because of section 230
if we were in any other industry there'd
be obligations to disclose the contents
to disclose the practices to comply with
the service in terms of service
agreements that the companies don't even
comply with their own terms of service
agreements because they're allowed to
say this can change at any time
so just basic responsible action that we
apply to adults who run companies i
think could attach to these internet uh
platforms and i like the idea of making
a quid pro quo they want some immunities
and there should be some duties
yeah i
understand about the quick pro quo and
also um what you're saying about basic
misunderstanding of what the first
amendment is is like
useful context
needs to be said um
part of what i was getting at was
would be with the elimination of section
230 and i don't know if this would be
relevant with a modification or a quick
pro quo kind of situation with section
230 but i was also just you know asking
if there could be a chilling effect on
on speech because unlike in the
newspapers newspapers don't just put out
what a bunch of people who don't work
for the newspaper say and the way that
platforms let anyone come in and say
their stuff so you know would citizen
journalism be basically kaput because if
a company's like yeah we're going to
censor this out because we don't want to
deal with liability issues
does that mean that you we don't see
someone's uh video footage of being
pulled over
by people i'm a little perplexed about
what exactly is the liability so so what
the police officer is going to sue
saying that this is defaming me
um but truth is a defense to a
defamation action
and the fact that it it
there is uh video footage it might be in
fact useful against deep fakes which are
a serious problem
but if it actually happened
that's that's not going to produce
liability
yeah i guess i guess um i'm thinking not
i'm thinking about preemptively people
just being like well
you know in a way
it's like with the fairness doctrine
where technically the fairness doctrines
the broadcasters are obliged to cover
controversial issues of public
importance and when they do so they are
obliged to cover you know give both
sides
multiple points of view right and so
when they did cover controversial issues
they showed both sides um or tried to or
most often did
found a way to balance out the coverage
at least over the course of their
schedule um but one effect was sometimes
a that of an avoidance of showing
controversial issues of public
importance and especially on the local
level i would say more than the national
level let's just not even get into this
this crisis because it's controversial
it's too much workforce and so i'm one
and so there is i i
think the fairness doctor was well
intentioned it had some flaws but it did
sometimes have a chilling effect on
speech and i'm just wondering if
adjustments to section 230 might also
have a chilling effect on speech
regardless of the fact that it shouldn't
because
defamation you know if you show a crime
it's not defamation it's
a crime it shouldn't work that way but
if platforms decide well we'd rather not
take any chances then you have that sort
of chilling effect so i get the question
and yes the fairness doctrine in
particular did lead
some mainstream broadcasters to say we
want to stay out of this because we
don't want to even figure out what are
the competing points of view which was
in tension with their obligation to
cover uh issues of importance so it was
really up to the
enforcement uh will of the federal
communications commission whether or not
they actually demanded compliance with
both of those duties and and that varied
depending on the administration um but i
don't think that's the issue
that's presented those dynamics are not
presented uh with section 230 or maybe
more a better way to put it is we have
the lessons of the misapplications and
negative effects of the fairness
doctrine that should guide any revisions
of section 230. we can learn from
experience
and i just want to underscore again that
the platform companies currently edit
they moderate they do all the time they
take down all the time um and that's not
the question the question is what
incentives do they have and and uh
whether that we can learn in fact from
their compliance with the copyright laws
so we can create a safe harbor that they
can allow third parties to post anything
until someone objects because it's a
copyright violation and if they take it
down they don't face a liability
so there could be similar kinds of
approaches towards material where
there's a borderline question
yeah i appreciate that notion that like
let's learn from the fairness doctrine
where it succeeded where it failed and
kind of apply that moving forward and
also i think a lot of liberals and
progressives point to the fairness
doctrine and say if we could just get
that back we'd fix all of our problems
and your book notably does not do that
and in fact i didn't if i had a pdf and
could have done a search like fcc versus
ftc i feel like the ftc comes up more
than the fcc and that you you're
thinking about like consumer protection
yeah the nftc model more than an fcc
model and i wonder this takes us into
solutions even more the second half of
the book if you could talk about
what that means to use a consumer
protection model and what role the ftc
could play in in
reforms changes whatever um
great
well thanks uh
federal trade commission versus the
federal communications commission and of
course there are state
counterparts consumer protection and
also regulation of uh media at the state
level and even localities you think
about the
local cable monopoly the local
governments have a role to play here
that they have not exercised and could
actually be much more vigorous in
requiring public service dimensions when
they award a monopoly to a cable
provider
so three buckets of solutions are what i
propose none of which alone will solve
this problem and even altogether they're
not going to solve the problem but i
think that they could make some dent in
the problem
the first bucket
is to as i've already been suggesting to
hold the internet companies the large
platforms responsible for their actions
as if they were adult companies and
there are several areas
copyright enforcement i would go further
than the current takedown practices and
require
payments for the
circulation of copyrighted material
uh australia required facebook to
actually pay
when a third party posts copyrighted
material and initially facebook said
then we're leaving and a week later they
came back
uh the european union has similarly said
copyrighted material that's circulating
on social media
there's a virtuous circle that's
supposed to be
represented by copyright that then
protects the time and energy of those
who developed these stories so that they
can then go and report a new one if a
third party can just distribute it
without any payment there goes the
possibility of new
investment and new reporting so that's
another example um we've talked about
section 230 uh and yes uh i do think
that there are uh other kinds of
responsible actions including um
actually uh making making uh child safe
zones i mean there's ways you could
design portions of the internet that are
safe um or are better for different
kinds of viewers
disclosure about what uh are the
practices that they're using as i've
already mentioned would be another the
second bucket are
ways in which the government regulation
could strengthen
uh the news industry whether it's
digital or con
not digital um
by actually uh developing
uh any trust exceptions for example so
if local news providers were exempted
from antitrust problems they could
collaborate around back office expenses
they could collaborate
even in doing investigative journalism
you think about the model of propublica
which is a national organization but it
invests in for example building a big
database about
which doctors are abusively using their
prescription powers in the opioid area
and they make that database available to
local news providers who then can write
in the local story
if you think about similar kinds of
commons that can be created the
associated press is another example
um where can we bring that up to date
for the internet age that required uh
construction interpretation of the
antitrust law um so that the associated
press could not exclude uh new
participants in it so in order to
maintain the small players allow
different kinds of aggregation and
collaborations
another aspect in this bucket of the
laws that govern conventional media um
uh
and also the internet would be privacy
laws consumer protection laws that could
apply to the internet companies and how
about protecting our data
so that when we um supposedly are
getting these internet services for free
um that maybe we get paid or at least we
get some kind of disclosure or something
like that the third bucket is direct
subsidy uh plus uh public education uh
critical media education everybody
coming to mit or elsewhere
but also
direct subsidies like public broadcast
why can't we have a public internet that
has public service duties
why can't we actually have even more
investment in public media it has to be
carefully separated from any content
decisions so it's not the government
making those choices i should disclose
i'm on the board of
wgbh here in boston
which is very mindful of that and tries
to have plural sources of funding
but another kind of subsidy that i think
could take even more importance is
recognizing um
the role of the tax code
so the role of the tax code in uh giving
uh tax credits
for example to advertisers who pay for
ads in local outlets
for taxpayers who subscribe to a news
service
there could be a tax credit that those
are elements of the currently pending uh
local new sustainability act which
actually has bipartisan support joe
manchin supports it kristin cinema
supports it because if you're a
politician you know you need local news
another kind of subsidy in that tax area
is actually the whole area of nonprofits
so a nonprofit organization
is subsidized indirectly by the
government by the fact that it is not
taxed and donations to it
produce tax benefits to the donator
those are ways in which the government
can boost non-profit organizations and i
think it's one of the reasons we're
seeing conversions of some news outlets
from the from the for-profit to the
non-profit
we just saw that happen in my hometown
chicago
where a radio station merged with a
for-profit newspaper to become a
non-profit
to share their back office and their
digital services but also to have the
benefits of this tax status to be able
to get foundation grants and other kinds
of grants
so i think that those are examples of
subsidy and i'm sure that there are
others critical media education i do
think is really important so that uh
digital natives above all
uh learn to assess where's this coming
from uh if there's no name attached to
it why do i trust it um and and how do i
understand what i'm seeing and what i'm
not seeing
yeah one of the points in the book where
i got the most exciting i never thought
i'd be so excited about learning more
about the tax code and fi but but when
you're at the end and you're talking
more about 501 c 3s and this as a as a
venue for journalism i thought this is
this is quite brilliant this is like a
really clear sort of road map for
certain kind of change that could really
help you know tax breaks for say making
more hires to a local news source that
kind of thing um
and your point about politicians needing
local news i think um is is a good one
and i i think the sort of flip side to
that is like c-span uh years ago being
invented in part as a venue for
politicians who want to be seen more
outside of the so-called filter they
don't want to be edited they just want a
camera i want to be seen and uh local
news
um as something that could be boosted at
the other end of the spectrum like
c-span was
you know years ago um could be a sort of
path forward
um
i
i'm gonna ask you one last question then
and then i see we've got questions in
the room and i want to open it up um but
create making transforming your local
newspaper into 501c3 is quite doable you
can look up how to do that that can
happen people can innovate from the
bottom up to make that happen uh in the
same way that say uh art movie theaters
could be totally destroyed if they
didn't become 501c3s it's the only way
forward for them at this point right
there other kinds of support the brattle
theater absolutely that was my next
thing support the bridle that's the only
way forward for so many venues now is
going to be seeking 501c3 status they
they you know they need it so i see a
clear
exact sort of how that would work there
are other parts of what you call for
that i see how they would work in theory
but then i'm like well given the way
congress is right now given the the
far-right
takeover of the republican party
how can we make any these changes happen
um
is it is it
you know are there you
you've listed your your uh sort of
bucket list here you know your list of
one two three right so what are the
practical step forward to actually enact
these things is it about legislation is
about you know what are the different
levels that would have to be in play to
make some of these changes really happen
you know it would be great to improve
the government generally but in the
world that we currently live in
uh one approach as i've already
suggested is to find those topics where
there is bipartisan support and there
surprisingly is a fair amount in this
area
and that even includes uh expanding the
jurisdiction of the federal trade
commission
uh and there's interest in doing that so
there's legislation that's possible but
there's also administrative action
and if you elect a president who
appoints someone to run the federal
trade commission who cares about these
things
then the federal trade commission can
actually
shift its resources to this area
enact regulations
use its subsidy powers which it has use
its investigative powers they already
have those powers it's a question about
is that a priority similarly elect a
president who actually cares about the
antitrust laws and wants to enforce them
and makes appointments to the department
of justice anti-trust division and the
federal trade commission of people who
actually believe that the antitrust law
applies to the large internet companies
another thing that's possible though is
to recognize state governments state
governments are currently considering
some of these subsidies using state
taxation
for the non-profit news and even the
for-profit news
local new sustainability act versions
have been introduced in several states
and i have a group of students who are
working on having it introduced in
massachusetts
in addition fascinatingly this is kind
of uh
a pool bank shot
if there are a couple of states that
start to regulate guess what the large
internet platforms and the large
broadcasters will go to congress and say
please would you legislate because we
are subject to these competing rules in
different states
so
actually there's a lot that can be done
to motivate congress or to work with
other actors um i do think that
philanthropy matters a lot for my third
bucket um and uh
and i think that universities have a
role to play you know in many states in
the country right now if you go to the
state capitol
the only
journalist who is covering what is going
on
is a university or
high school
journalist
there have been serious proposals that
local news actually now
is in many places a function of colleges
and universities well if so
then let's
actually support it
um it will require philanthropy it may
require public dollars but if that's the
only place that's actually covering the
legislation that's being debated
or the corruption that's not being
exposed
there should be some some uh public uh
commitment uh to cover it you know we
have evidence that those communities
that lose local journalism having
notable measurable increases in
corruption
by the government and corruption by
private actors
flint michigan i am so haunted by the
story of flint michigan and the lead in
the waters and i talked to the public
health official there who said well
actually we were lucky and i said what
are you talking about she said we were
lucky we had really good local
journalism and then she said this
sentence that i still can't get out of
my mind she said we have hundreds of
flint michigans in the united states but
there's no one covering it
so i think there are lots of steps that
can be pursued
public actors private actors
you know you talk about citizen
journalism i think one of the
interesting possibilities is how
new platforms can be created where
citizen journalism can be amplified
that's great that's very helpful and
it's very
just really specific i appreciate that
and and i just was going to add as a
side note like
the the college and university point i
think is so important and it also makes
me think about radio and how radio has
it hasn't died people are making
millions of dollars on it right but you
know
a local radio station is not local in
any way there's a pre-pro playlist the
local dj just might say words between
the songs that he or she has been told
to play whereas college radio is where
people actually make programming
decisions and could potentially be doing
say local reporting by playing uh
unusual music you know so i think that
that pointing to college radio is
another a good example um
i want to switch to uh we can have some
questions from people whose faces we can
see for sure but we also have some in
the the q a here um there's one here
from ed burshinger uh the right wing
loves to cite justice brandeis
saying that we need more speech not less
many right-wing pundits are also
originalists as i understand it just as
brandeis was not an originalist
consistency may be too much to ask but
is there an effective response to those
who insist on free speech above all
other rights
if consistency mattered we would have a
very different kind of uh jurisprudence
you know we have uh conservatives who
claim to be originalists until they're
not
um so the
what i tell my students all the time is
we just have to know how to speak all of
these dialects
and and it is possible to make arguments
about speech
as an originalist as a pragmatist uh as
a structuralist all the different
methods
um what i think is probably um
most valuable here is actually to point
to just as brandeis's own
uh beliefs uh in the market but in a
regulated market
um and to identify the ways in which
he and others on the court
showed that
you need a regulation in order to have
freedom and that's true about free
speech
if people really want to be a ritualist
the most amazing thing is that the first
amendment would not apply
uh to the states
um uh their the first amendment actually
says congress shall make no law
so it wasn't until the civil war and the
civil war amendments
um that were enacted that and then
gradual decisions over the course of the
20th century that the courts decided to
apply the first amendment to the states
the originals had no idea that this was
going to happen this is all judge made
law and i would just go a little bit
further and say the creation of
protection for commercial speech
that's something that courts invented
the press is what was protected
uh the definition that speech applies to
any
digital communication including an
algorithm
that's not in the constitution that's
judges who are making the decision these
are therefore
decisions that can be argued with and uh
debated
thank you
um tl i see your hand is up
hopefully mike hopefully my internet is
still working good enough thanks for a
really um
conversation point i i found the the
um
the comment and the work uh of thinking
about the ftc rather than the fcc really
interesting way in and it it made me it
reminded me of
um
danielle citron was kind of trying to
get folks to reframe thinking about harm
in cyberspace as civil rights violations
and i i as somebody who works in kind of
internet studies i found that a really
generative move really useful so my
question is
are there other
existing levers or rubrics
or legal frameworks that might also you
know to add to the pile of come at it
this other way that's going to get us
into the interesting productive terrain
thanks
thank you thanks for that coming and for
a shout out to danielle citron whose
work is so terrific
i'm a huge fan she has a new book coming
out very soon um what i can say uh i'm
sure that there are many but one that
comes immediately to my mind is public
utilities
so
the idea that um
there are some goods that are so
necessary
that
the
and yet the structure of the markets are
such that they're so capital intensive
that they won't produce real competition
so people have to buy
water have to buy electricity
have to buy phone service
and there isn't real competition
that led to the creation of this idea of
a public utility
privately owned but public duties so yes
you can go ahead and take advantage of
your market position
but only if
you make sure that your service is
universal you do not discriminate on the
basis of fill in the blank etc etc
public utility is a framework that i
believe could be applied to the big
internet platforms
and they would remain private they could
make scads of money but they'd have
duties
yeah thanks and you know i just i got me
thinking about the rural electrification
administration and how after world war
ii they basically decide phone service
is not a luxury it's not just for
businessmen or for urban people how can
we get phones
everywhere everywhere in rural america
because it's it's a public utility it's
not just right
lyndon johnson
his project and it came from being a
school teacher in texas and seeing what
people's lives were like
yeah yeah
now i'm thinking about robert carro's
yes opus and how one of the big stories
is is johnson getting electricity back
to you know absolutely that made him
like just getting electricity
right yeah
made his career in certain ways um
there's two uh uh questions here that
are um somewhat historical from suzanne
singer one is you know why not bring
back a modified fairness doctrine and
this might be a good chance for you to
talk about what you call at one point i
think the awareness doctrine uh in the
book um and the other question also from
suzanne singer was what about anti-trust
legislation that used to be enforced re
how many tv stations and other media one
company can own in one market which is
something that is quite relevant to the
book that but maybe we haven't hit it
yet
great two two wonderful comments and
questions um
let me say something about annie trust
first and then go to the fairness
doctrine so
the antitrust law is another you know
era of
louis brandeis
the recognition that uh large
corporations actually can exercise power
of the sort that um
concentrated governmental power uh
jeopardizes personal freedom and
democracy and the
progressive era produced the very first
antitrust laws and the idea that
actually private power can jeopardize
democracy
fast forward to the 1970s
university of chicago
economist developed an idea that the
antitrust law shouldn't actually be
concerned with democracy
it should only be concerned with
consumer prices
it shouldn't be concerned with
concentrated uh wealth or concentration
of market power should only look at are
the consumers
having a cheaper price
they were successful without even
changing the legislation
their theory was adopted by judges who
interpreted the law and prosecutors who
interpreted the law
apply it to the internet
there are no prices
and so the idea that there's any
check checked on is there too much being
charged or not being charged
it's one reason there's been so little
any trust action with regard to the
internet
well there are currently uh
now a bunch of people are saying let's
go back to the original idea about
antitrust they concentrated private
power is a problem
uh that it's a problem for democracy
it's a problem for markets and then
there's some people actually suggesting
that
the internet is not for free we are
giving over our data we just need to be
a little bit more imaginative to
understand what a price is
and then we could actually regulate here
so lena kahn who's now you know at the
federal trade commission
uh the department of justice
tim wu who's in the white house these
are people who believe what i've just
described
whether there will be action or
political will i don't know but it just
goes to show that
antitrust remains a viable tool if we
have the political will and the legal uh
enforcement
if it doesn't happen at the national
level it could happen at the state level
antitrust is a power of state
governments as well
um fairness doctrine
well as heather said before
the justification for the fairness doc
doctrine was predicated on the scarcity
of the signal
that in order to get a license to
operate a radio or a television station
uh an applicant had to
promise
to fulfill certain duties and one of the
duties was to provide coverage of
controversial subjects coverage of local
news and a fair sampling of competing
viewpoints
we don't have a scarcity rationale
for that kind of regulation when we're
dealing with the internet nor with
newspapers
those kinds of issues
about fairness and competing points of
view have never
never applied
to those outlets for that very reason
the fairness doctrine was upheld legally
in the supreme court
um because of this anomaly this unusual
circumstance
um but it's an exception to the usual
rule
that editors have free speech rights
that viewpoint uh is itself protected uh
and therefore um the editorial judgment
uh by a uh uh
a internet platform by a newspaper by
cable
uh is actually protected by the first
amendment as you have written about
heather
the talk radio
and the development of right-wing media
is all about the first amendment um and
uh there's not any constitutional way
and i'd be worried about someone coming
up with one that would force um fox news
actually to have competing viewpoints
um also it might actually make people
think that they're really doing that
because they're not
um
but in any case um i think that the
fairness doctrine also faced a political
demise
uh the big broadcasters in particular
organized even after the supreme court
victory
and it lost the political support
and so ultimately
under the reagan administration
it was
really disconnected and it really took a
while to the clinton administration for
it to go off the books finally the fcc
eliminated it all together
i had a student though in uh who
responded to my telling of this history
who said well why can't we have an
awareness doctrine and i love this idea
and i give him credit in the book
and the way that i've tried to flesh it
out is how about a doctrine that simply
requires
the disclosure
of the parameters being used for
moderation of content on an internet
platform
or
to go a little bit more affirmatively
to give an option to people
to actually elect to see
information that is different than what
their preferences would amplify
so a group of undergraduates at the
university of chicago
in one semester for a class project
came up with something that they called
flipside using uh you know
algorithmic tools machine learning to
study content to be able really cheaply
to identify competing viewpoints
in publicly available media
about various topics
now i have no disrespect for
undergraduates at the university of
chicago but if they could come up with
that in one semester
imagine what the genius engineers
at meta
at twitter could come up with if we
really actually uh required or maybe
even just gave incentives
for them to come up with awareness
techniques for their users to actually
find ways to have serendipity to
encounter um content that's not just
amplifying what they um have looked at
before
i love that example of flip side from
your from your book and um
you know just the kind of the way that
these students found a way to
i mean it seems to me all about the
interface like you can't just be like it
can't be like click click click and you
make the point in your book that it
would take the average person 250 hours
per year to or 20 250 hours each year to
read everything they click off on that
they're agreeing to like terms of you
know yeah this this is right because
nobody reads that stuff so you'd have to
find a system where people um
actually want to engage with the choices
that they're making about how their data
is being shared and what's being shown
to them
um the other thing i wanted to add was
um about the the history of the fairness
doctrine in its fall is that when it was
starting to kind of teeter one thing
that i find really interesting is that
there were so many conservative and
right-wing groups that actually wanted
to keep it whereas now that you know
they call it the hush rush law everyone
was trying to make rush limbaugh shut up
by bringing it back but you know phyllis
schlafly was in support of the fairness
the nra supported the fairness doctrine
because they're like if people are going
to go out there and attack us we need a
legal way to attack respond and exactly
right of reply well you know we used to
have people supporting democracy in
elections also yeah exactly and that's
yikes yeah
um we have a question from one of our
graduate students that's uh in the the q
a area over here i'm going to read it to
you
thomas tomas guarna from cms here the
note on section 230 as subsidy and
public investment in early internet
infrastructure is extremely interesting
it does seem like this public investment
ended about 20 years ago and today would
maybe be unlikely that 230 were passed
do you see a change here and how the us
government invests in communicative
infrastructure and how would you make
sense of it
wow very interesting you know i i don't
have access to the defense budget
but the defense department still is
investing dramatically in infrastructure
that includes communications
infrastructure and remember the internet
itself was a darpa project
um and the uh the boost to the
telegraph
came from a national security concerns
um and so i i i think there might well
be uh investments that i'm just not
aware of
um but i agree we have had kind of a
falling off
of what was the big tradition in the
united states 19th century especially
early 20th century especially but 1950s
1960s
government priming the pump by investing
in infrastructure
you know to some extent
that's been the argument of uh the biden
administration not to get partisan about
it but a build back better is to invest
in the infrastructure to invest in roads
and bridges and you know a big part of
that bill is broadband there's a whole
internet portion a very serious
commitment about tech investment um so
they're just at the moment is a
political log jam
why has that fallen off well we've had
you know about 30 40 years of an attack
on government with the claim that it's
not effective and it's not it's not uh
an efficient way
uh to allocate resources what's really
striking is the united states is likely
to fall behind leave communications
technology let's just talk about
batteries
and let's talk about um
any kind of uh environmentally uh
sustainable energy other countries have
much more investment in those kinds of
infrastructure than the united states is
and so if you want to buy
a car that is an electric car now you're
going to be using parts that are made in
other countries that are underwritten by
their governments
so if you just take it as a national
security uh concern we're going to have
a competitive disadvantage from the
failures to invest in public
infrastructure
you that's a that's a great answer um we
have uh
several people in the in the chat who
want to talk about twitter and elon musk
and i'm going to read these two
questions uh one is from nancy weaver
who asks is elon musk's assessment of
twitter as our new town square accurate
and if so what do you think about his
offer to purchase
and the other question from joseph
benzemann is a question on the current
news item of elon musk attempted by
twitter one reason i've heard many of
his supporters give for desiring his
ownership of the platform is that it um
his musk's approach to free speech would
be more libertarian than its current
ownership i'm wondering what are your
thoughts on this situation is there a
good way to handle must bid to own
twitter and that's a good opportunity
for you to talk about the uh
libertarian weaponization of the first
amendment that you go into in some depth
in the book so two-part question one
just about the notion of of twitter as a
as a town square and then this other one
about the libertarian issues
you know i think that some of the
biggest users of twitter in this country
are journalists
all the journalists i know use twitter
to find out what's going on
i don't know if
the vast public uses twitter
so i'd be reluctant to call it
a public square
for that reason
uh in in certain circles it's very very
common but in others it's not uh tick
tock a little bit more uh dominant i
think
um
and also you know the platforms uh
gaming platforms which have much larger
users than any of the conventional media
and have their own messaging boards
which are uh outside of public view
altogether
um twitter is a very fascinating
phenomenon they've had a toxic culture
at twitter
um and their own uh corporate board
governance has been broken for a long
time put aside their
content or their uh
what it is that they actually promote in
their services just that that's been a
problem uh in the board in general and
people that i know who have served on
the board have said they have corporate
governance problems um so i'm actually
disappointed that someone like elon musk
is not going on the board to straighten
that out um buying the company uh you
know depends what he's going to do with
it i have no idea what he would do with
it the idea that he would eliminate uh
editing uh is unimaginable the vast
majority
of moderated uh activity on twitter and
on any of the platforms is to eliminate
spam
you have to have moderation
there has to be moderation there will be
moderation so the only question is along
what lines another related question is
when you're using machine learning tools
to do the moderation which everybody has
to do because the scale is so monumental
is what level of error do people accept
and that is something that is worthy of
discussion i'm not singling out uh
twitter i think it's an issue for all of
the platforms and i just myself believe
that if you look at the choices
from the selection of the data sets on
which the machine learning is taught
to
the
level of error that's accepted to the
level of feedback and accounting that is
used to then feed back into the system
to modify the data sets
all of that
those are choices that the companies
should actually be exercising much more
responsible action over
and much more valuable than say let's
make the algorithms transparent not only
the people at mit will understand the
algorithms that's not what needs to be
made transparent it's these choices that
are made by human beings that are not
made by
um uh by uh by computers
um i think that uh the
libertarian idea about the first
amendment is very confusing because on
the one hand it suggests no regulation
and as i've already indicated there's
always regulation
in conventional media there's editing uh
in internet platforms there's editing
there's always editing
there was a golden age in some ways of
the internet that was
fueled by a kind of libertarian ideology
that claimed this is the new free space
we don't need a government well guess
what
not true
um
mike my colleague jack
goldsmith wrote a very important book
about how
the internet depends and internet
companies depend more on conventional
laws
than other companies do
and turn to those laws to enforce their
practices
they're not libertarian it's a question
about what policies you want or don't
want
um and
which is in fact always the case there
is no freedom without some kind of
control there is no private property
without some kind of rules the question
is what are the rules
when i call a certain direction in
supreme court jurisprudence libertarian
first amendment
what i mean is that there's a kind of um
ruthless hatchet
being taken to any governmental
regulation
on the grounds that it's speech
and once we say its speech the first
amendment prohibits government
regulation it's kind of a mindless
as i say hatchet or weapon
and it's bringing back what some people
are calling it the new lochner well
lochner was a decision
made by the supreme court in the early
part of the 20th century didn't use the
first amendment used the due process
clause of the 14th amendment
but had the same effect creating the
power of five justices the majority of
the supreme court to strike down
democratically enacted laws on the
grounds that it interfered with freedom
in that case it was freedom of contract
or the property rights of employers and
using that theory the supreme court
struck down wages and hours like a
legislation any kind of workplace
regulation
rules about unions same thing happened
then when the new deal started the first
three years of the new deal
the five members of the supreme court
struck down the new deal saying it
violates freedom of contract private
property in both instances the country
rebelled the country said this is a
disaster we need health and safety
regulations and after the depression we
need a new deal that's going to actually
regulate the economy and i suspect that
will happen with this new lochner the
use of the first amendment to strike
down
federal trade commission action
any trust action
uh because it goes too far but in the
meantime there's a lot of damage uh that
is occurring with the supreme court you
know striking down all kinds of laws
saying that it's speech and look we have
lower courts that have said anything on
the internet is speech
even if it's a sale
uh and initially internet companies said
that's why
sex trafficking cannot be regulated
because it's just speech
on the internet
congress actually rejected that and
agreed to amend section 230 so that
there's a carve out for sex trafficking
on internet platforms is about political
will
um
well i think maybe we could end on that
extremely powerful note
um
thank you so much uh martha you know for
joining us and for uh just unpacking all
of these really complicated and
interesting and important vitally
important issues that you raise in this
new book um it was just great to be able
to talk with you about it today and
thank you um
to our graduate students and all of our
participants who showed up too as well
and for the the questions that you sent
us via chat um i will just end by saying
that we have just one more colloquium uh
public colloquium event uh this semester
which is on may 5th we're having fred
turner from stanford uh out here in
person with mary beth meehan coming in
from uh providence to talk about their
book seeing silicon valley
um so it's a it's it's a book of photos
with with um a text by by fred turner
and um i have a discount code if anyone
wants to buy for 30 off um as well from
your i think it's yeah university of
chicago press so feel free to drop me an
email if you didn't if you weren't on
that list where i sent out the discount
code but i am i'm hoping to see many of
you there uh in person it's in person
for mit community and via zoom from
those outside of mit so um see many of
you there i hope and a good night to
everyone thank you thanks so much great
questions thank you